let's see who else we've got here let's
go to oh I don't know I mean I'm just
going going crazy here with area codes
let's try let's try the people er
something's up with the phone system
there's almost like too many people
holding let's try the five six one area
code who's calling today from 561 hello
yes that's you I have a question
it's not really relating to the debate
but I called the way before and it was
it was I think it was mentioned on your
interview that Joe Rogan's show and it
was about that we of that one woman who
try to get you fired from Boston College
because you tweeted that it's not
progressive to vote for someone are not
vote for someone based off of their race
gender well you yeah yeah yeah I said
that excluding candidates merely because
of their race or gender is not
progressive and she tried to get me
fired from Boston College for saying
that right so what you said on the Joe
Rogan show and imply that what she was
saying was racist and I called asking
what you thought about that because
racism isn't applicable to white people
and I really wanted to hear your
thoughts on that
because yeah who says you can't be
racist against white people well okay we
have to really take a look at what
racism is because if we're going by the
definition that it's discriminating or
seeing a race as above or below another
that's a very skewed definition where
racism should be examining the social
economic and political system and within
this nation and other anglo-saxon ations
there's only one group the in-group
which are white people that have
political socio-economic power to
oppress No totally disagree with you I
think that's a losing let's that's a
losing redefinition of racism
you can be there's no question that
power dynamics are really important in
thinking about whether racism translates
into straw
kiryl oppression but you can be racist
no matter what your races and no matter
what one other people's race is I think
it's exciting is extremely problematic
but why is my definition of problematic
when it takes into account the
historical implications of what white
people as a group have done to oppress
people it's just not it's just not the
right it's just not accurate you're the
first definition you gave is the right
one and so I think there's two things
because it's not what racism you're just
you're coming up with a new definition
it's like if I said you know well you've
presented another definition right and I
think I'm presenting the most accurate
and holistic definition of racism and
that's what so for you the most accurate
definition of racism is one in which no
one can be racist against white people
is that what you're saying that's what
you said that's how you started the
conversation you said you can't be
racist against white people in Western
anglo-saxon countries you can't be
racist I always in this nation in this
and this nation specifically because
that's what I've studied with racism
this nation specifically you can't be
racist to white people because people of
color don't have the power okay hold on
a second just hold on one second okay
let me let's just take it let's let's
build it up if a Hispanic person says I
don't like white people because they're
white is that racist no it's not racist
however you don't know however just how
is it not racist it's not reason because
okay well I can't I can't say Hispanic
because Hispanic is an ethnicity so I
understand what you mean by let's say
person of color a person of color cannot
be racist towards the white person
because they don't have the power okay
all right fine so so look we're going
through just indulge me if if a person
of color says I don't like white people
because of their whiteness that's not
racist according to you if they complain
if a company says if a company says we
are not going to hire white people at
this company is
racist yeah it's racially bigoted it's
racially bigoted we like I think it
slice of your left that you represent is
very small but it is extremely
problematic and I completely disagree
okay I follow you because I think you're
really reasonable and I subscribe to you
and I think it's great what you do and
what you're saying is extraordinarily
unreasonable trust and I reason then one
thing is not like yeah it's not wrong
because we have people studying race and
racism for decades and anthropologists
have come together to you're just wrong
I'm I'm a Hispanic immigrant to this
country if I said I'm going to hold on a
second if you really want to get down
into ethnicity I'm actually asking Ozzie
but this is a whole this is why this is
so stupid
if I say no matter what my race is if
I'm white if I'm Hispanic if I'm
Ashkenazi if I said the David Pakman
show is not going to hire white people
as a policy because I just don't like
having white people around that is
racist by any definition of the word and
any deviation from that is completely
prejudiced but racism needs to take the
holistic definition of prejudice plus
power listen now you're just playing now
you're just playing semantics games I'm
gonna let you go cuz the audience I
think is tuning out but you're just
wrong I would urge you to rethink your
views and I hope that that does not
infect any of the Democratic candidates
dialog because that is self to saying is
a disaster it's it's it's
extraordinarily damaging and fortunately
it I don't think it's super prevalent
because what you're saying doesn't make
any sense okay well I mean I'm shocked
by that I'm shocked by that